-I love this show so much.
-Thank you, Seth.
-You've been here in past years,
talking about your great show
"Detroiters," which I also love.
It has been so fun.
We met as writers at "SNL,"
and to watch you
doing sketch comedy like this
makes me very happy.
You're doing it with Zach Kanin.
-That's right.
-John Solomon, both writers
you met at "SNL" as well.
What was your -- was it fun
to sit in the room and write?
And do you feel like
you've gotten better at
writing sketches,
as far as the speed
in which you write them?
-Mm...No, not really.
-Yeah.
-I feel like we still --
Coming from "SNL,"
I think we still have
that same work mentality,
which is, like,
you sit around --
You get there early,
but then you just sit there
and [Bleep] and talk,
and then you're like,
"Oh, my God!
We got to do something!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So it's still that same thing.
-Right.
-We need that ticking clock,
I think.
-You have some great guest stars
from your time there as well --
Vanessa Bayer, Cecily Strong,
our friend Conner O'Malley...
Will Forte --
one of my favorite sketches.
And I feel like Will --
You used him
as well you could ever use him.
It was an airplane sketch.
There's what Will's
looking like.
And, um --
[ Laughter ]
I mean, do you want to give up
the premise of this sketch?
-Sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so he --
A long time ago, 30 years ago,
took a flight, and a baby --
he was going to London,
and a baby cried the entire time
and ruined his flight
and then ruined his trip
to London.
So he vowed to get revenge
on me, who was the little baby.
[ Laughter ]
But then, while I'm going
on my honeymoon,
he's like, "Remember me?"
[ Laughter ]
-And there's a lot of
close screaming.
How -- like, how hard was it to
get through a sketch like that
in a two-shot with Forte
screaming at you?
-It was so hard.
Akiva had -- The director.
-Akiva, also from "SNL."
The Lonely Island produced
this show, I should know.
-Yep. And he kept having him
to be like,
"Tim, you're on camera, man.
You can't just be like..."
[ Laughter ]
Forte would come in and be like,
"I hope my breath is okay,
buddy."
[ Laughter ]
-You --
"I think you should leave"
is basically the statement
of thesis for this whole show.
A lot of the characters
are people
who just fully commit
to something.
I mean, that is a perfect sort
of opening sentence,
that sketch
that we just showed --
of people who will not admit
they're wrong.
-Right.
-And it was fun to watch
because there are some things
that I remember
even you having written
at "SNL" --
-Uh-huh.
-You know,
that for whatever reason
didn't work there
that sort of flourish here.
Was that fun to find things that
you had thought were funny
maybe five years ago
and now finally have them
fully realized on camera?
-Absolutely. It was so great.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, things that didn't work
on "SNL" or like, yeah.
It was so nice to be able
to bring them back and be like,
"Okay, it is okay."
-[ Laughs ]
-And I am okay.
[ Laughter ]
-There were so many
guest stars I recognize
that we're friends with.
There was one scene
where it's basically a --
What do you call it?
A focus group.
-Uh-huh.
-...to talk about things people
want in a new car.
-Yeah.
-There was an actor in it.
And I do want to show a clip
of him, but real quick --
Did you just find --
How did you find him?
-His name is Ruben Rabasa,
and he auditioned,
and we were blown away.
He's a very good actor.
-And I will say watching this,
I thought, "Oh, my God,
you've found the perfect person
for a Tim and Zach sketch,"
'cause he's real crazy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's take a look
at what I'm talking about.
-What do we think
it should look like?
-Sleek.
-Good.
-High tech.
-Aerodynamic.
-Too small.
-I'm sorry?
So when you get in there,
you're like,
"If the steering wheel fly off,
I'm toast."
-Oh. Okay, I don't know why
we'd make it too small.
-I think it's a good idea
and I stand by.
-Okay. Maybe it could have,
like, a sporty look.
-Great.
-Teacher's pet.
[ Laughter ]
-Any other ideas?
-Stinky!
[ Laughter ]
-I just -- I don't know what
I love about him so much.
But it is --
-And I just realized,
showing Forte and playing him,
they got a real similar look.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Not every character on the show
looks like that.
-Yeah.
It must be really weird
when you, as an actor
who, that's your actual look,
come in and you see Forte.
And that's what they made him to
look crazy in a sketch,
and you're just like --
-"Hey, that's what I look like."
-Yeah. "That's my, like,
normal look, man."
We've talked about your kids.
You've got one of each.
Penny is your daughter, yeah?
-Yep.
-And she shows up on
your Instagram.
She's kind of an Instagram star.
-Yeah, she is.
-Does she love the camera?
-She does. She really does.
But last time
I came on the show, I --
We talked about her,
and when I got home --
You know, she does funny bits,
and I ask her
if I can record them,
and sometimes she says "yes,"
sometimes she says "no."
But she did a funny bit, and I
was like, "Can I record that?"
She's like,
"You gotta pay me money."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "You know what?
You're 100% right.
I respect that."
So now if I record one.
I give her money.
-Oh, wow, just on the recording?
-Just -- yeah.
I'm like, "Yeah, okay."
She's like, "5 bucks."
-Okay.
-She'll negotiate with me, too.
-With this one,
I think it was Wi-Fi hot spot.
Is that what we're gonna watch?
-We had just moved and we didn't
have Wi-Fi yet,
so she wanted me to set up
a Wi-Fi hotspot with my phone.
-Okay. And I think she was
pretty cool about it.
Let's take a look.
-Yeah.
-Get me a Wi-Fi hotspot now!
[ Laughter ]
Now, I said.
[ Applause ]
-Yep, yep, yep. Penny!
10 bucks is coming home
for you, Penny.
-What about Buster?
Buster is older? Younger?
-Buster is older.
-Gotcha.
And does Buster love the camera?
-Hold on. Let me put this
in my pocket. I don't wanna...
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
He doesn't like the camera
as much.
-Gotcha.
-He's super funny, too,
but he doesn't want me
to record him, so I don't.
But he, like, dances
around the house and stuff.
-I also appreciate a kid
who doesn't love the camera,
so give that to Buster for me.
-Oh, my God.
-I mean, I don't want
to just reward, you know,
people who love the lens.
-That's great.
-Yeah, yeah.
We need some behind the camera
people as well, you know?
-Yes, people who don't want
to be in front of the camera
get paid, too.
-Yeah, absolutely.
Buddy, congratulations
on the show.
I cannot tell everyone here
how much you have to see it.
And it's just always such
a pleasure to have you here.
-Thank you, buddy.
-That's Tim Robinson, everybody.